you said two different things bro he
said that they're happy being single so
why don't they just continue being happy
and being single but I'm not doing that
this dude
oh God boyfriend I know who's still
single I I just telling people can leave
doesn't matter I think this thing about
dying alone is just nobody's saying that
you keep saying no one else is saying
that I have been feeling the podcast
since I sat here it's not about feelings
no no no no no no no no no no it goes go
by what people say don't try and put
words in people's mouths no one said
that so it doesn't matter how you feel
it's about go on what was said because
no one said that and you keep saying
that over and over and over again and no
one said that to you so I don't know why
you keep saying it